you're gonna go to war as savage brought
the war to us the greatest gladiator
naps in the history of the world Son of
Krypton vs bat of gun
down I wanted it you began already time
you learn what it means to be a man
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie and so new
Batman V Superman promo little bit of
new footage but mostly I wanted to talk
about doomsday I said the vast majority
of you guys are mostly familiar with him
from the death and return of Superman
he's appeared a few times in the comics
but there's always the question as to
like where he ranks in terms of like all
time Superman villains because I feel
like some of his stories aren't the best
Superman stories there are like a couple
of good Doomsday's stories you know
obviously the death and return of
Superman is probably the best that
hunter prey is another good one because
that was like their first rematch after
doomsday killed Superman and he came
back so that actually happened pretty
close to the death and returns storyline
it was also a big cyborg superman Dark
Side Story so you know I kind of like
the resolution because it leads to
Darkseid coming back to as Superman
comes back I know everybody is wondering
like what is the next step for justice
league because if you kill doomsday and
I obviously like he'll come back because
that's this whole thing like you kill
him and get stronger who's going to be
the next film for justice league because
doomsday seems more like a Superman
villain so he would arguably come back
and the Man of Steel sequel which is
still happening even though it seems
like everyone's more excited about the
new Batman trilogy man of steel 2 is
still in development we just don't know
when it's going to come now I know Lex
Luthor creating doomsday in Batman V
Superman seems like a departure from the
comics because originally doomsday rose
from the Kryptonian underworld a
scientist created him in when he was a
baby he just kept killing him and
killing him and killing him so that he
would evolve into something stronger and
stronger each time he died he would come
back stronger so it's kind of like this
uber Frankenstein arc where doomsday
recognizes Superman is a Kryptonian kind
of transfers all the hate that he has
for his Creator who was a Kryptonian
onto Superman and has it out with them
so yeah doomsday killing machine sent to
kill Superman but also in doing so they
give some more motivation to the
character like he's not just a killing
robot the reason I think doomsday
doesn't rank super high on everyone's
list of DC villains he's very powerful
but as a character he's just not as
compelling to say like the Joker he's
kind of like this big dumb brute
Frankenstein character now he has
evolved slowly over time so we'll have
to see what Batman V Superman does with
them like if he's actually a character
or if he's just like a finger puppet for
Lex Luthor like I'm gonna create this
devil and just let him go like is there
a character inside this monster but
unless you've been reading DC comics
continuously especially Superman's
titles
for the last like 10 or 15 years you may
have missed a couple big doomsday arcs
there was a story called sentence where
Lex Luthor regrew are like recreated
doomsday in a lab it was intended to be
this special homecoming kind of thing
because it was the hundredth issues like
the issue that he came back and that Lex
Luthor brought him back in was the
hundredth issue since doomsday killed
him during the death of superman arc so
I've been a hundred issues and were like
okay we're gonna bring back doomsday in
lex luthor's going to be the one to do
it now in this version of the story he
uses Superman's Kryptonian DNA to bring
him back but obviously in the movie and
Batman V Superman is going to be in
Zod's DNA now it ended up spiraling into
this much bigger thing where dark side
tries to create this clone army of
Doomsday's but really the whole point of
the issue the whole point of bringing
doomsday back to fight with Superman
again was so that Superman could have
the last word like tell him off like you
will never be able to beat me again and
at this point doomsday had actually
evolved a mind so he could actually
understand what Superman was telling him
and Superman was just telling him to
GTFO it was like you know finally
telling him off now obviously Greg pok
brought him back during the new 52 so
doomsday is always going to keep coming
back but that was before the new 52
reboot now if you haven't read it New
Krypton is an amazing comic book arc
it's a great Brainiac arc it's a great
arc for Superman in general and in their
kind of almost doing a version of it on
Supergirl that TV show right now I mean
not really there's Kryptonian things
happening on Supergirl they're not
literally doing the New Krypton art but
I think that they could if you do want a
really good short doomsday story i would
recommend going with Greg pox doomsday
during the new 52 it's a little bit
different origin story but it kind of
acknowledges what happened during the
death and return of Superman he tells
the story as if it's like a dad telling
his daughter this bedtime story it
involves Zod talking to kara zor-el so
it kind of invokes some of the stuff
that's going on with Supergirl TV show
right now but obviously it was written a
long time before the Super Girl TV show
but if you are watching it invokes a lot
of familiar things so it might be a
little bit more fun but if you want to
go to the classics just start with death
and return just getting back to the
movie it looks like there's a long
process between Zod's Kryptonian looking
body here in this monstrosity here so in
case you missed it in the last big
trailer there was this incubation device
it looked a lot like a twisted birthing
chamber from the original man of steel
movie so it looks like Lex tries to
reverse-engineer the Kryptonian birthday
says is going to be really disgusting
really weird and really awesome at the
same time like I really feel like Zack
Snyder's going for David Lynch levels
awareness like eraserhead levels of
weirdness and if you haven't seen a
razor head be careful and don't eat
lunch before you watch it but I guess
that is a funny way to think about
doomsday and Batman V Superman like Lex
Luthor's eraserhead baby this is
disgusting creation that he unleashes on
the world I obviously the movies gonna
treat him in a more straight up way like
here's this monster to defeat all these
big heroes but I just can't wait to see
like an in credits tag where a doomsday
fist just like slams up through the
rubble like I'm not dead I'm coming back
that's actually good question for you
guys let me know in the comments so we
know you killed doomsday he evolves
comes back bigger stronger do you think
that they're going to do that same thing
with these movies now remember Zack
Snyder said that Batman V Superman story
line isn't based on any particular comic
book arc but as many things as they do
change and many of the little things
that they change they do pay homage to
the original stuff in the comics I
really do feel like it'd be good to
bring it back in a man of steel sequel
I'd really rather see Brainiac in the
Justice League movie the list of
villains big enough to warrant the
Justice League is actually pretty small
so they change is actually harder to
find a villain that's compelling enough
that all those superheroes have to team
up to defeat them if you guys don't want
Brainiac in the Justice League movie let
me know which villain you would rather
see that you think that they'd
realistically be able to do it just
because there isn't a whole lot of flash
arrow stuff happening right now I'm
going to name the reverse flash ring
giveaway winner from this week in this
video so congratulations to dana's you
in last week's reverse flash ring
giveaway just be sure to private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
get your contact info so what's going to
happen is next week is still going to be
really Star Wars heavy hopefully you
guys have seen the movie but I'm been
doing some bonus videos just for each
character just because they're so
amazing if there are any DC like Batman
V Superman flash arrow videos that you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments so why you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
learn all about the Knights of Brenda
organization inside the new Star Wars
movies and you can click here for all my
Batman V Superman trailer videos thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you